Understanding what
people are doing
can help your app better
adapt your users needs.
I'm Mark Stogaitis and
I'm going to show you
how you can tell if your users
are walking, running, cycling,
or in a vehicle
and how to use it
to improve your app experience.
This could be done with
the activity recognition
API on Android.
Once you set up the system
in your application,
activities are
automatically detected
by periodically reading
short bursts of sensor data
and processing them using
machine learning models.
We've recently
trained new models
as well as added
the use of Bluetooth
to significantly
improve the accuracy
and reduce the latency
of detected activities.
Receiving recognize
activity callbacks only
takes a few lines of code.
Start by connecting to the
activity recognition API
and defining where you want
connection callbacks to go,
then request activity updates by
specifying a desired detection
interval and a pending
intent where you'd
like activities delivered.
Your application will
receive callbacks
with extras containing an
activity recognition result.
This contains a
list of activities
that the user may be doing
at a particular time.
So what can you do with
this extra information?
Well, for example, if
a user starts running,
you'll get a callback indicating
the most probable activity
is running.
If the confidence
is 75 or higher,
you know you can act on
it and show notification
asking if they want to
start tracking their run.
Or when an app is in use
and the user starts driving,
you can offer up a switch
to car mode dialogue.
You can also use it
for historical cases
so just showing your users
where they parked their car
or how long they spent
commuting to work each day.
Reducing memory consumption
is important to keep
phones running smoothly.
When using the API,
a common use case
is that an application
wants to monitor activities
in the background and perform an
action when a specific activity
is detected.
Typically, when
developing for Android,
you'd use a persistent running
service to handle this.
But sadly, that consumes
a lot of resources.
This API removes that
burden by delivering
the data via an intent.
The application specifies
a pending intent
callback typically
an intent service,
which will be called
with an intent when
activities are detected.
So there's no need to keep
the service always running
in the background.
Minimizing battery
usage is also important.
On devices that have
significant motion sensor,
the battery is conserved
by stopping activity
reporting when the
device is still
for an extended period of time.
It'll resume once
devices move again.
I hope this gives
you a taste for how
your app can make use of the
activity recognition API.
This is just the beginning.
Watch out for new activity
types being added soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]